[Music]  Kate Upton and Justin Verlander are  officially husband and wife  the famous couple tied the knot in Italy  following the Houston Astros Stars win  over the Los Angeles Dodgers in Game  seven of the World Series Kate and  Justin got engaged in early 2016 after  three years of dating I was completely  surprised there was this moment that  before he proposed I was like now I just  have to join dinner  Kate debuted her stunning sparkler at  the Met Gala in May 2016 Justin actually  designed the reported 1.5 million dollar  ring himself et went dress shopping with  Upton earlier this year and here is what  she teased about her wedding day style I  always like to add a little flare of  sexuality to any outfit I'm wearing  [Music]